there's been a stunning new development
in the war in ukraine huge blasts at a
russian air base appear to have
destroyed a number of russian warplanes
that's according to the satellite photos
anyway the explosion earlier this week
happened in crimea the
russian-controlled territory in southern
ukraine charlie dagetta has more from
the front lines
the massive series of explosions at the
air base in crimea has sent shockwaves
far beyond the russian occupied
peninsula
new satellite images appear to show deep
craters and scorched earth with the
ukrainian government claiming at least
eight russian warplanes destroyed
the blast sent stunned beachgoers well
over a hundred miles from the closest
front line fleeing for safety
a deep strike for ukrainian forces says
retired u.s marine intelligence officer
hal kempfer and frankly that changes the
front across the board
and if they can continue the momentum if
they can continue to do deep strikes if
they can continue to to make gains
across the kirchner lost
they might be able to push all the way
across that southern flank as a direct
response to the assault on that air base
russians retaliated increased shelling
and missile attacks on towns and
villages like this one according to
local commander roman coolio with an
american flag on his uniform he told us
how western-supplied weapons saved his
soldiers so you were running out of
weapons
yes yes
until the howard says drive yes
yes how bad was it really bad it was
catastrophic situation catastrophic yes
yes
but it has been a brutal back and forth
along a battered front line in the south
this children's playground bears the
scars of fighting in a virtually
abandoned village trapped in a no-man's
land between the furthest point that the
russians have been able to advance and
ukrainian forces determined to hold on
to this territory
76 year old anna schepel is one of few
residents left oh my gosh
and the wall
what did you think when you came back to
this
i thought i would have a stroke she said
i was paralyzed
i wish that the russians felt what i
felt at that moment every minute every
hour for cbs morning's charlie dagda
near mikalive ukraine
charlie thank you